others first time oh [ __ ] it I'm gonna
stairs is getting obnoxious
maybe I could like that what for just
somewhere else I'm just gonna read in my
journal wait
oh I got all this stuff I thought for
sure I was gonna get aqua Fortis sorry
guys
I should have shipped that alright so
we're going to go back to let's see here
I don't really exactly remember act back
to where we were kind of early in the
beginning the clothes smell that blah
blah blah sorry my why of course just
[ __ ] great
oh jeez really ah look so disgusting
what the hell is that
yeah whatever
oh [ __ ]
guess I'm not going there too
and I think it's over here actually
yeah that goose oh yeah I bet this gonna
remove the goo so I think it's back here
if I remember correctly
nope it's not then I'm kind of confused
Mavis town in the wine I don't know wait
what's this oh yeah this where let's see
if this no it's still there
then I'm kind of item out of ideas let's
see if I I got a slight headache this
one right
someone refilled the chest for me
nope probably not
[ __ ] cockroaches
confused PETA is confused
oh yeah I couldn't go there so and I
came from there oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I
know we were gonna go
how wait I can't go there
oh that's gotta be it
hi I could move he sat down by the cash
bar
Wow Wow gasping for air sweated pour
from his forehead into the Sun meal
something oh yeah so now we're going to
go down in the laboratory and create
this stuff that we from the chemistry
things that we collected and
I took for granted that he was gonna not
going to be here but apparently is it's
gonna take it easy now don't manic
anything stupid now
alright ah light thank you good good
everything is in order
are you down there nope he's up there
though scaring the hell out of me
alright so let's do this is that and
we're gonna I know that because I don't
know the order though I don't hope there
is one
yeah close one two three I was just
kidding not doing anything don't mind me
don't mind me
when you die is he coming for me oh
we're cool
real cool I'm just minding my own
business here oh god is he coming
downstairs
dolphin night
oh [ __ ] just-just-just doing chemistry
here what the hell alright
enough goofing around aqua regia oh now
I remember he said aqua regia instead of
aqua Fortis that's why I was such a
douche forever to find I guess I'm gonna
switch these burners [ __ ] burners
[ __ ] he's a burner
dammit thought I had this
Oh
circular motion huh okay burners are in
action we got four different colors very
nice very beautiful
all right and we got to turn this on yes
we Reggie's in action
I'm not scared of you you [ __ ]
alright
there we go how to redo this apparently
go alright just get a good with these
and
we're done
that's very neat man drink that looks
tasty acid part of acid and where are we
supposed to help pour it down there I'm
not sure straight out
No
supposed to drink it or what
what am I supposed to do with it
oh yeah I'm supposed to use it on the
stuff to get on that oh that's not good
news and I don't have many of those
left's I don't know why I waste them
I'm so [ __ ] scared that's why all
right can't get up there so I guess this
is my only no just don't mind me I'm
camping in the corner huh
can't go in there either
it's a bunch of dead stuff
that's my son are you doing I'm all
right
it's gotta be some way maybe I can use
these to get up
all right hustle sold that wasn't too
hard
all right it became impossible to avoid
the commotion in the streets begged for
his attention he as he opened the
shutters the French soldiers opened fire
on the two young men fighting back their
voices were silenced in a haze of gun
smoke these lines are just so horrible I
don't
Oh God
everything is red and full of dead and I
feel like I have better days than this
one what about you guys
holy oh it's everywhere
why not [ __ ] hates me have I done
and yeah this looks person
or
um assuming we're gonna head down there
but I just want to make something clear
I do not
whatsoever want to go down there that's
for [ __ ] sure
but let's do it anyway
refinery
excuse this asset of ours
okay so we're good no hard feelings
right is that your brother
all right after enduring three days in
Algiers a sailboat was finally arranged
to take him across the Mediterranean Sea
to clear out her having reached British
territory was just a matter of serving a
cabin on SS or tarry I headed for London
Wow
this does not look good whatsoever oh
geez
I lit this up I've so few of those I
don't want to waste them sure is dark in
here yeah I agree yes and there's a good
reason for it but you can light the lab
now if you wish there's how long for the
darkness that is stay close
careful not to stray what's the reason
why is it so dark pay attention
dandelo it's important that you keep
going straight and make sure not to
stray ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't stray walk straight don't stray
the thing is I have no [ __ ] clue
what's trainings so I guess that makes
me [ __ ] but I know that I'm going to
keep straight so let's do that
walk straight don't stray walk straight
don't straight
walk straight
I'll look at that and that great
oh I hate when that hints appeared look
at that hint that means someone's gonna
[ __ ] me over all calls on the walls I
don't like that oh that was just a
bottle of poo oh geez
what have I done to deserve this mother
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay seriously nope
nope I gotta take a break choose me what
the hell